which of the following graphs can
represent the hyperbola y squared over
nine minus x squared over four is equal
to
one and we have our four choices here
choices a and c open up to the top and
the bottom
or up and down choices b and d you can
see d here open to the left and the
right and you can see within the ones
that open up to the left to the right or
up and or the up down ones they have
different vertices so i encourage you to
pause the video and see if you can
figure out which of the following graphs
represent the equation of a hyperbola or
the graphs of this equation right over
here
all right so there's a bunch of ways to
think about it one thing you might say
what's the center of this hyperbola and
since in our equation we just have a
simple y squared or a simple x squared
we know that the center is going to be
at 0 0 if the center was anywhere else
if the center
was at the point h comma k
then this this equation would be y
squared minus the y coordinate of the
center sorry not y squared it would be y
minus k
so y minus the y coordinate of the
center squared over 9
minus x minus the x coordinate of the
center squared
over 4 is equal to 1. and in this case
well this is just the case where k and h
or h and k are both equal to 0. so we
just get you could view this as y minus
0 squared and x minus 0 squared so the
center in this case is going to be at 0
0 and you see that for all of them
now the next question you might ask is
well is this going to be opening
up and down or is going to be opening
left and right and the key thing to
realize is is you just need to look at
whichever term and when it's written in
standard form like this when you have y
minus k squared over something squared
minus x minus h squared over something
squared is equal to 1 or it could be the
other way around the x square the x term
might be positive and then the y term
would be negative if we're dealing with
a hyperbola so the key is to just look
at whichever term is positive
that will tell you which direction the
hyperbola opens in since the y term here
is the one that is positive it tells us
that this hyperbola is going to open up
up and down
now you could just memorize that but i
that's never too satisfying i always
want to know why does that why does that
work
and the key thing to realize is
if if the y term is positive then you
could set the other term equal to zero
and the way that you would set the other
term equal to zero in this case is by
making your x equal to the x coordinate
of your center and that's 0. so if x is
if you x is equal to the x coordinate of
your center and this term becomes 0 you
can actually solve this equation you can
solve y squared over 9 equals 1.
so if
x is equal to 0 so x is equal to the x
coordinate of its center
then this term goes away and you would
get y squared
over 9 is equal to 1 or y squared is
equal to
9 or
y is equal to plus or minus 3. so you
know that the
coordinates
the x coordinate of the center plus or
minus 3
that they're on the hyperbola that
they're and so you know that's going to
open upwards and downwards so you go to
the center the x coordinate of the
center plus 3 and minus 3 are on the
hyperbola
notice over here plus 3 and minus 3 are
not on this hyperbola in fact if plus 3
and minus 3 were on this hyperbola you
wouldn't be able to open up to the right
and the left and so that's why whichever
term is positive that is the direction
the that you open up or down with or if
it's so if the x term was positive we
would be opening to the left and the
right for the exact same reason and you
could see if if we did the other way
around if we had the y equaling the y
coordinate of the center so this term if
the y term was zeroed out you would end
up with negative x squared over four is
equal to one which is the same thing as
x squared over four is equal to negative
one which is equal to x squared is equal
to negative four i just multiplied both
sides by negative 1 there and then i
multiplied both sides by 4 and this has
no solution
and so that's why we know that we're not
going to intercept the we're not going
to intercept the line we're never going
to have a situation where y is equal to
the y-coordinate of the center
so that's what so y is never y is never
going to be equal to zero in this case
in cases b and d why there are points
where y equals zero so the thing to
realize is whichever term is positive
that and whatever variable that is so if
it's for the y variable that's the
direction that we're going to open up in
and when i figured out what the actual
vertices are we saw that the point 0
plus or minus 3 are on the graph so a
looks like a really good candidate if we
look at the other choice that opens up
and down it doesn't have 0 plus or minus
3 on the graph it has 0 plus or minus 2.
so we can feel pretty good about
choice a